the study of philosophy is as much
hindered by the conceit that will not
argue as it is by the argumentative
approach this conceit relies on truths
which are taken for granted and which it
sees no need to re-examine it just lays
them down and believes it is entitled to
assert them as well as to judge and pass
sentence by appealing to them in view of
this it is especially necessary that
philosophizing should again be made a
serious business in the case of all
other sciences arts skills and crafts
everyone is convinced that a complex and
laborious program of learning and
practice is necessary for competence
yeah when it comes to philosophy there
seems to be a currently prevailing
prejudice to the effect that although
not everyone who has eyes and fingers
and has given leather and last is that
wants in a position to make shoes
everyone nevertheless immediately
understands how to philosophize and how
to evaluate philosophy since he
possesses the criterion for doing so in
his natural reason as if he did not
likewise possess the measure for a shoe
in his own foot
it seems that philosophical competence
can consist precisely in an absence of
information and study as though
philosophy left off where they began
philosophy has frequently taken to be a
purely formal kind of knowledge void of
content and the insight is sadly lacking
that whatever truth there may be in the
content of any discipline or science it
can only deserve the name as such truth
has been engendered by philosophy let
the other sciences try to argue as much
as they like without philosophy without
it they can have in them neither life
spirit nor truth
section 67 is this great passage that
ends with this this statement that let
the other sciences try to argue as much
as they like with that philosophy
without it they can hand in them neither
life spirit nor truth that's a bold
statement on Hales part and you might
say what does that got to do with all
the things that I've sketched up here
well you know when the other sciences
the other disciplines the other fields
of knowledge are asserting themselves
but they're doing so in a way against
philosophy or sort of dismissing it
taking it for granted not being
adequately philosophical themselves they
they end up limiting their themselves
without actually realizing it and they
are going to lapse either into this side
or into this side whether we grasp it or
not so it's not like we have four terms
here you know the argumentative rays
linear in approach the sort of common
sensical don't bother me with your
reasoning I've got facts on my side sort
of approach philosophical science and
then other sciences what he's saying is
if other sciences are not adequately
philosophical they don't stay here they
wind up on this side and they wind up on
this side probably a weird hybrid
mixture of both so let's look at these
these two approaches we've got the
argumentative approach and we've got the
conceit that will not argue and we've
looked a lot at the argumentative
approach already we don't need to say
awful lot more about it it's overly
critical it's taking advantage of the
fact that subjectivity is in fact
negativity the fact that the world is
not you know completely finished product
the fact that we can look at things from
multiple perspectives to tear things
down to say that's not any good and it
ends up in a what he calls you know a
vanity or a futility a skeptical
standpoint that we're gonna see come up
over and over again that is it's not
satisfying it doesn't satisfy what the
the reasoning human being actually needs
and you know
what's what's the opposite of skepticism
a kind of dogmatism and oftentimes
people want that sort of thing precisely
because they feel the pain of you know
being caught in this void where things
don't seem to matter so they latch on to
something and every culture has some of
these positions to offer at least some
of its members our culture is a wide
array of things that you could you know
sort of ready-made step into and be part
of you know you want to be an unthinking
Christian that's quite possible you want
to be an unthinking atheist that's quite
possible that both is equally you know
backwards stupid undirected as each
other you want to you don't have the
sort of Vantage point of being the
Christian critic you want to be the
atheist critic you want to play around
with criticism but not actually applying
it to yourself and see the that you know
your standpoint might need some
dialectical retooling knock yourself out
your there's websites - voter - that
sort of thing
you want to be a stoic and read
Epictetus and walk around on the
enchiridion in your back pocket and you
know pop up quotes every once in a while
you can do that in a sort of you know
blockheaded here's here's my dog my cat
away or you can also do that in a I'm
gonna criticize everything from the
standpoint of stoicism kind of way or
you could actually you know read
Epictetus you'd probably have to read
more than just the enchiridion have to
read the discourse is - that the
enchiridion is a best hits off but you'd
have to actually like think through
these things and Hegel saying philosophy
real philosophy is going to occupy a
kind of that a Rousseau Chilean meaning
place but something in between these two
let's look now over here at this tiny
bit on this conceit as Miller's
translating it that will not argue says
the study of philosophy is as much
hindered by the conceit that will not
argue as it is by the argumentative
approach that gets things wrong and
thinks that because it can argue against
things and raise objections that that
put it into
you know the development of the
dialectic this conceit relies on truths
which are taken for granted and which it
sees no reason to re-examine it just
lays them down and believes it itself
entitled to assert them as well to judge
and pass sentence by appealing to them
how often do we see people raising
objections because they are a fan of
Bertrand Russell or Ayn Rand and
Bertrand Russell said this or antor and
said this or you know pick newer people
Richard Dawkins said this or you know I
should probably pick out a few theists
as well you can read Augustine in a kind
of a blockheaded just I'm going to take
everything for granted sort away
although you know if you really read
Augustine that's not going to be the
case but you're gonna say Augustine said
this or you can be one of those those
Thomas whose what I call a
fundamentalist of the Summa look it says
that I here on this page Thomas put an
end to that that question or you know
you don't even have to go to philosophy
to do that neuroscientists have told me
this because I saw this thing on the
Gawker or you know we know all about
who's a racist who's a sexist who's a
classist who's a business to the baddest
because I saw this ish distance you know
this blog post and Jezebel that's
basically just consumer culture of the
mind there that's what hinkel's are
actually talking about it could be just
you know relying on text books it can be
you know just reading the newest thing
that pops up the whole point here is
that somebody has a few thoughts and
they don't bother to re-examine them
they're not doing anything dialectical
with them because they're not saying
well are these really sufficient can
these they actually say something about
themselves do they do they self other
you know what don't they include can
they extend to what it is that they
don't include can they address rival
points of view the person here doesn't
feel the need to do that because they
already they already know it they've
already got it figured out maybe if they
don't have the whole universe figured
out they've got their town figured out
they've got their house figured out
they've got their laboratory figured out
they've got the church figured out they
don't need to be bothered with any
thing else so he says in view of this
it's especially necessary that
philosophy should again be made a
serious business to many people and
Hegel's time in his view are pottering
around the philosophy there's too many
dilettante involved in the game and
that's giving things a bad name by the
way is this a new thing read the
Republic and you'll see Socrates saying
the same thing philosophy is being you
know given a bad rap by all these people
who are doing a crap job with it and you
know somebody I want to come along and
do philosophy right
Plato's talking about himself in that
case right so he says in the case of all
the other sciences art skills and crafts
everyone is convinced that a complex and
laborious program of learning and
practice is necessary for competence see
where this is going don't you why isn't
that the case for philosophy ask
yourself - is it different in our time
than it is in the time that Hegel is
complaining about how many people throw
the word philosophy around and have no
clue what it means or just a dimmest
idea or they've read one book and
they've really read it well you know
they've read Bertrand Russell's history
of philosophy and now they know about
the whole history and they know where
everybody fits in and they never
bothered a question whether Russell was
a biased source or even worse if they
read done the dorrance you know history
and philosophy you want source that's
not perfectly good that that's one why
is it that there's apprenticeship
programs in all these skills and you
wouldn't hire somebody to do work for
you who doesn't know what they're doing
who doesn't have a certificate it hasn't
earned the right to call themselves
Ernie men but you're perfectly fine with
anybody whatsoever calling themselves a
philosopher or you know all people out
there who have no idea what philosophy
is talking about this person's a
philosopher that person's a flop
philosopher
I mean why get upset about
you know Needle deGrasse Tyson or
Stephen Hawking denigrating philosophy
unless you actually have put in the time
to know what philosophy could mean going
beyond say just an intro class almost
you had a really good interrupt teacher
a really good intro text and you really
applied yourself see these are important
questions and there are they're
perennial questions when it comes to
other things we think that there's a
body of knowledge out there that you
have to acquire not only do you have to
learn information you have to undergo a
formation of yourself that information
has to become a part of you now that you
become a walking encyclopedia but that
you're able to apply that knowledge
you're able to figure out what applies
at what time what's relevant what's not
relevant you're able to see how things
fit together
why would it be any different for
philosophy if philosophy actually means
something now in philosophy is just as
Mel Brooks
you know conveyed as I've heard so many
times when I tell people that I'm a
philosopher being a [ __ ] artist then
presumably there's no actual skill but
it's interesting because other people
who are essentially [ __ ] artists
meaning artists who work with you know
various types of [ __ ] sales for
example there's a thing called
salesmanship you can actually teach
somebody how to sell things better how
to you know read the customer what to
say what not to say there's a body of
knowledge common a very difficult thing
to do that so easy to be funny
there's a good comics put a lot of
thought into it
they study each other the same thing has
to go for philosophy you cannot be a
philosopher just going off and
pretending to be Descartes and
meditative you know on things by
yourself or with your you know little
friends a circle over there who went to
that particular institution and read
those five articles and you know trade
them back and forth you can't really do
philosophy well with
seeing what other people in the field
are doing without trying to make their
achievements your own and trying to
assimilate that and then try to move
past them so he says what's the problem
here you know a lot of people will for
example when it comes to shoe making
that's not something we can relate to so
easy but shoe making they think that
it's not enough just to give somebody
leather and some tools and say all right
make me some shoes you actually have to
know what you're doing let's think about
in terms of culinary arts that's
probably something that we can relate to
a little bit more in our culture which
is foodie obsessed that has you know a
whole bunch of cooking shows and things
like that you can actually watch a
famous chef put together one of these
great recipes and follow along and say
oh that's a cool ingredient and then
watch the judges eat them and oh I taste
the saffron in that you know you can do
that that doesn't make you a chef you
walk into the kitchen and start you know
getting your ingredients out and start
working with them you'll figure out real
quick whether watching cooking shows is
actually going to convey expertise to
you buying cookbooks that's not enough
either it probably helps to take a clean
class or you know again in my case it
probably helps to have had a formation
when you were a child having a mother
who was essentially a gourmet cook you
know who would spend hours on on meals
and we would sit there as kids and watch
her or sometimes we'd apprentice by
she'd say all right you're gonna do this
you're gonna do that
you're gonna do this I know how to break
down a chicken because I saw my mother
do it time after time after time I know
a chicken heart tastes like because
those are the little delicacies that she
kept for us when she was turning a
chicken into three meals and she'd give
them to myself and like my sister that's
what philosophy is like as well the
problem is is that everybody assumes
that because they've got natural reason
or common sense or you know some
critical thinking capacities over here
that they're up to doing philosophy in a
serious way
but doesn't mean that they can't you
know write a philosophy paper that can't
read Plato they can't read Hegel but
they have to acknowledge the fact that
they're beginners or journeyman or
intermediates they're not at the level
of the Masters quite yet perhaps they're
not even equipped to make judgments
about the Masters so he says everyone
nevertheless immediately understands how
to philosophize how to evaluate
philosophy since he possesses the
criterion for doing so it is natural
reason you might as well say Hegel says
this is a great response that well you
possess the criterion for shoemaking
because you got a foot or you possess
the criterion for culinary arts because
you got a mouth and a tongue tastebuds
and that sort of thing
or hey you're you're a musician because
you got some ears no it's not quite so
simple as that it's a laborious process
so he says it seems to these people is
if philosophical competence consists
precisely in an absence of information
and study as it philosophy left off
where they begin and you know some
philosophers have actually been quite
detrimental in in saying things like
well philosophy is just thinking without
making any presuppositions or it's like
non dogmatic or it's different from the
other disciplines and that it has no
content
hey would say that's nonsense you guys
are actually giving a false image of
philosophy to people you're doing a
disservice to to them and to yourself
and a philosophy as a result so he says
the insight is sadly lacking that were
whatever truth there may be in the
content of any discipline or science it
can only deserve the name as such truth
has been engendered by philosophy now
does that mean that you know unless the
philosopher came up with important
biological principle it's not really
ain't good no but probably that
biologists who came up with that was
doing philosophy and not calling it
philosophy at the time we go back to
Protagoras you know in Plato's dialogue
where Protagoras said that many people
are Sophists they just are doing you
know things under cover so to speak
Plato would be willing to say that
to a certain extent those who are
actually thinking about the grounds of
their discipline thinking the big
thoughts thinking the ones that really
matter are doing philosophy they're
doing philosophy of this they're doing
philosophy of that and it gets
reincorporated into the discipline but
it is doing philosophy if you're
thinking about you know whether you've
actually got stuff right in how you're
applying things in your discipline
you're probably doing epistemology
you're doing critical thinking if you're
making arguments about your discipline
you're doing rhetoric are you doing
logic or dialectic if you're thinking
about what is the nature of the thing
that I'm actually working with how
should I comprehend it you're probably
doing metaphysics if you're thinking
about you know what are the important
implications for how human beings relate
to each other and what this means about
human beings you're doing philosophical
anthropology then we could go on down
the list for aesthetics for ethics for
political philosophy for philosophy of
language a whole bunch of different
fields all rolled into philosophy that
permeate the other fields this is an
angle standpoint on that when this gets
lost sight of the disciplines go this
way or do they go this way when in
philosophy itself loses sight of the
need to be rigorous the need to be a
serious business it winds up over here
or winds up over here and doesn't do
anybody any good
in place of the long process of culture
towards genuine philosophy a movement as
rich as it is profound through which
spirit achieves knowledge we are offered
as quite equivalent either direct
revelation from heaven or the sound
common sense that is never labored over
or informed itself regarding other
knowledge of genuine philosophy and
we're assured that these are quite as
good substitutes as some claim trickery
is for coffee it is not a pleasant
experience to see ignorance and a
crudite without form or taste which
cannot focus its thought on a single
abstract proposition still less on a
connected chain of them claiming at one
moment to be freedom of thought in
toleration and at the next to be even
genius genius that we all know was once
all the region poetry is it now is in
philosophy but when its productions made
sense at all such genius began only
trite prose instead of poetry or getting
beyond that only crazy rhetoric so
nowadays philosophizing by the light of
nature which regards itself is too good
for the notion and as being an intuitive
and poetic thinking and virtue of this
deficiency brings to market the
arbitrary combinations of an imagination
that has only been disorganized by its
thoughts an imagery that is neither fish
nor flesh
neither poetry nor philosophy
section 68 is going to bring back up
some old enemies old objects of
criticism that Hagel has already several
times addressed in the course of this
this preface and at this point you might
actually be saying yeah come on Hegel
that's enough but we're getting close to
the end of the preface so bear with him
for a moment there's a really important
point that's being made here he's not
actually using the term that we use
nowadays
which we might call present ism and when
we're talking about them what we mean is
judging everything from the standpoint
of the present it's you often used by
historians who want to say that you know
if we want to understand ancient Greece
we can't just take our categories of
understanding and just sort of like I
pasted them back onto ancient Greece for
example a lot of times we want to say
well you know ancient Greece as an
entire culture as a civilization as if
there was such a thing you know that you
could generalize about in such ways was
much more open to an accepting of
homosexuality than the last say 200 300
years of Western culture had been until
fairly recently yeah their evidence for
that will be you know looking at things
like you know Plato's symposium and the
jokes that are being made their
discussions about male male homosexual
relations Sappho's poetry all sorts of
things like that and what's important to
keep in mind is that the Greeks didn't
understand the difference between
homosexual heterosexual in quite the way
that we did for them and also for the
Romans you know and again we're really
generalizing really painting things with
a broad brush here it doesn't apply in
every case but they tended to see it
less in terms of is there a you know
same sex attraction or intercourse or
something like that and they much more
tended to see the you know Georgia the
aspect of it as being being penetrated
so it's fine to be the penetrate or not
so good to be the penetrate T and so you
know if you actually wanted allergies to
this we'd have to talk about something
much more like you know the the down-low
culture where people say well I'm not
really a whole sexual excitement I'm the
one who is penetrating where there's
some opprobrium attached to that right
present ISM would read back all that
sort of stuff or they would say for
example well you know the ancient Greeks
- if we want to make it them all to be
bad guys look at that jerk Aristotle
saying that women are defective men you
know or that some people naturally
deserve to be slaves well we know from
the present perspective that that's not
the case so what a dummy he was what a
dummy all those Greeks were to have
slavery the problem with this is that
it's assuming that our present vantage
point is the one that sort of counts for
consciousness throughout all of history
and it doesn't see history in a galleon
fashion as a set of advances of
consciousness which by the way I should
include this too often time include
options where you could be going up to
the next phase but you could also be
declining you could also be falling back
to previous phases history for Hegel is
a hard one set of achievements that we
should not write off we should not treat
us you know sort of consumer commodity
culture for the intellectual life or for
you know upworthy articles or things
like that we should we should actually
have a certain kind of reverence towards
the brutal labor that was required to
dig ourselves out from our you know our
previous ways of seeing the world our
previous understandings of the human
condition here's a great example Hegel
says that you know the human the human
species as a whole had to develop from
an understanding of power relations in
terms of tyranny moving to aristocracy
and then finally moving to something
like democracy and that politically that
happened early but in terms of the the
spiritual life that didn't happen in
terms of truth that didn't happen right
away so you know under tyranny one man
is free one person is free under an
aristocracy some people are free visa
vie each other under democracy all are
free at least politically and he talks
about this in terms of the development
of religion and how long it took to
realize that everybody can have an
unmediated relation to God or everybody
can be the one who's in the right
vantage point not just the priest not
just the you know we go further back not
just the arbitrary person who's who
happen to have been born into the family
that carries out the sacrifices each one
of these things each one of these shapes
of consciousness for Hegel is like it
said a hard-won achievement that we have
to think through what do people want to
do instead from the vantage point of the
present as they're doing philosophy well
he says in place of the long process of
culture towards genuine philosophy a
movement is rich as it is profound
movement that's very rich at each one of
these points each one of these points
was a world full of subjects that we can
go back to and make sense of and
appreciate the vantage point of the
present offers is quite equivalent one
of two things
direct revelations from heaven God
speaks through me or not God world
spirit speaks through me anybody says
world spirit speaks through me in a way
that doesn't take all this into account
they're not a galleon science speaks
through me the the enlightened masters
speak through me pick whatever you like
the human heart I have
ashin I have sympathy I'm a unique
individual because I was doing that
before it was cool any sort of appeals
to like direct intuition are rather
here's the problem with them they're
rather arbitrary there's always carried
out from the perspective of the present
they try to give us the meaning of the
present and the reason why I put these
these arrows here is what they do is
they talk about the present when the
current Gestalt is but they don't
actually advance us anywhere they don't
continue us on the process and they
don't provide us with a retrospective
look back because if if we're going to
move from a it's going to be by taking
all of this and then moving forward Hado
would say so direct revelations from
heaven or sound common sense and sound
common sense is always the common sense
of this present moment at this present
culture this group of people common
sense is not as common as universal as
it makes itself out to be so he says
these are these are presented as it is
quite good substitutes you might add to
that you know relying on text books or
sparknotes or Wikipedia or you know not
reading Hangul and just watching these
videos would follow to the same thing I
would say you should be reading the
Hegel you should be thinking about the
Hegel he says these were assured that
these are quite good substitutes as some
claim chicory as for coffee
chicory is not as good as coffee it's an
air sauce
it's a substitute right and you know
when you're being given a substitute
once you've actually had the real thing
you you can't be quite content with it
says it's not a pleasant experience to
see ignorance and a crudite without form
and taste which cannot focus its thought
on a single abstract proposition still
less on a connected chain of them which
is what's required here claiming at one
moment to be freedom of thought and
toleration the next to be even genius
and you know we see this in our own time
as Hegel saw it in his you're always
going to have people who are really know
nothing
and yet claim to be the spirit of the
time or claim the third or the ones who
are going to articulate the new shape of
freedom the new shape of meaning you
know they usually often have great
slogans grave logos but it's all you
know superficial flash and there's no
substance there now he talks about
genius this is really interesting
he says genius we all know was once all
the rage in poetry is it now is in
philosophy in Hegel's time so what is
genius
the idea behind genius is that you've
got a person who is unique and there's
somehow hyper qualified hyper competent
they can't explain to you how it is that
they're able to do what they do they
just do it they're you know just super
extraordinary and they're using their
their you know in gaining them their
their gifts that are from within and
just deploying them so why are some
people great musicians it's not because
they practice more it's not because they
study the history of music and
assimilated they're just geniuses if
they has to do the history of music
Mozart looked at the previous musicians
and saw stuff in them that we couldn't
possibly fathom well does it work for
philosophy Hale says no he says look at
how it turned out in poetry people were
saying oh yeah this person's a genius
this person's genius this person's a
genius and what did it begin trite prose
and set of poetry or getting beyond that
crazy rhetoric garbage genius is not a
substitute for making things that really
matter and last so nowadays
philosophizing by the light of nature
which regards itself is too good for the
notion and as being an intuitive and
poetic thing again we see the appeal to
intuition and virtue of this deficiency
brings to market the arbitrary
combinations of an imagination that has
only been disorganized by its thoughts
an imagery that is neither fish nor
flesh
neither poetry nor philosophy
what he's saying is that geniuses are
it's not that they're not welcoming
philosophy it's just that they're not
going to do any useful work they they're
in effect dead ends they're not going to
take the process further and the trouble
is is that they're going to pretend to
be and a lot of other people are going
to look at them and puff them up as the
wave of the future
it's work it's the patience the labor of
the negative the you know the hard work
that's required to enter into the
phenomena themselves to subject oneself
to them especially when those phenomena
are past history human consciousness
you know damping yourself to another
person's consciousness that takes an
awful lot of work coming up with BS that
you pull just out of the air or out of
your feelings or out of you know
mishmash ink or randomizing things or
just trying to you know one-up everybody
that's not very hard but it doesn't lead
you anywhere this studying this
assimilating yourself to that following
through it lets you have the possibility
of moving beyond you know hey yo would
be perfectly willing to say I'm not a
genius I actually am not even a dwarf on
the shoulders of giants I am just
consciousness on the shoulder of giants
and I am able to bring these things
together in part because I've
assimilated all this this past stuff and
thought about it and if it weren't for
them I couldn't be where I am it's not
that I've got this thing within you know
inside of me that's you know a special
talent for systematization or anything
like that
and it's not like you know sound
common-sense is suggesting this this
procedure to me I'm actually pretty
alone while I'm while I'm putting this
together in 1807 rather it's that I have
followed out the past
developments the dialectical
developments of these shapes of
consciousness and now I see where we can
go from here